this week on quadriga afghanistan after
karzai chaos or new era
12 million afghans are eligible to vote
in the country's presidential election
on the 5th of april
it'll be the last such poll before nato
troops leave afghanistan by the end of
the year
if it goes smoothly it'll be the first
democratic transfer of power in afghan
history president karzai cannot stand
for a third term in office
but the signs are not good
the taliban have carried out a series of
attacks in recent days
and warned afghans to stay away from the
polling stations
fears of election fraud also threaten to
undermine the vote
corruption is among the many problems
that will await the new president too
along with ethnic conflict and the
challenge of building afghanistan's
shattered economy
your host this week
is ali aslan
hello and welcome to quadriga
afghans are headed to the polls to elect
a new president as the muhammad kharzai
reign is coming to an end so the
question is who will follow him who will
be the next president of afghanistan and
perhaps more importantly what challenges
await him that's what i want to talk
about on today's show together with
three experts all who've been following
events in afghanistan very closely
welcome to
malaise dowd who is an associate
research fellow with the barcelona
center for international affairs he has
worked for the afghan government and a
number of afghan and international ngos
guntak naba is the former head of
deutsche welles asia program as well as
dw's former diplomatic correspondent for
asia and the islamic world
and
sven hansen is a senior editor for asian
affairs at the german daily newspaper de
tagus saiton he has traveled frequently
to afghanistan and in the past has
helped train afghan journalists
gentlemen welcome to you all the
elections
are about to take place a few days
from now malaysia let's talk about hamid
karzai first and foremost his 12-year
reign is coming to an end 12 years
that's the equivalent of three terms for
a german chancellor so a lot of time
actually to do good
or rather the opposite my question would
be
how would you evaluate his tenure as
president what do you think his legacy
will be
thanks so much i guess we need to
remember as you said that this is the
second longest pres head of state we've
had in the past 100 years and
a few want to compare president karzai
to anything else is the past presidents
or heads of states we've had and in all
honesty he's been the most restrained
and patient president we've had another
very long time
what he achieved to me the most
important thing is number one that now
we have a state it's weak it's
ineffective in some ways but this is a
state that we had lost during the civil
war and then taliban era number two
there's relative democratic uh practices
in place at the same time we have
relative pluralism it's not perfect
there are lots of challenges but we are
progressing we are moving forward
number three um i would say the level of
cohesion he has created amongst the
leadership of the country both the
ones who came from abroad the so-called
technocrats and also the so-called
warlords the former warlords now they're
all sitting together
and they have almost shared the same
goals and and
aspirations and these are the main
achievements of president karzai because
he was the one who brought everyone in
who integrated almost everyone in power
i know there are also downsides to this
but this was one of his main
achievements a rather positive
assessment than
from malaysia's doubt kuntak nabe would
you agree would you say that the hamad
karzai era will be remembered fondly
that's
depending on who you are belonging to
which group to which tribe in
afghanistan
i'm rather skeptical about that very
positive
resume you gave
he developed
as a person and in his position
he was installed as a puppet of the
americans because they wanted to have
somebody after
the taliban were driven off from
afghanistan at least mostly
so they selected him it was their choice
it was not the choice of the afghans he
was installed after bond conference
and in the beginning he was probably
seen by majority of the afghans as what
i said before a puppet of the americans
but then he developed into somebody as
you said who tried
to
let's say
reunite the different factions and
groups and ethnical groups in
afghanistan and by that he was rather
successful right
but on the other hand
what he did not achieve was
corruption is still
in afghanistan prevalent
and about the ethical
divisions in afghanistan he couldn't
change very much so i'm not that
convinced that he was that great guy
while you touch upon many important
points ethnic divisions corruptions all
we will come back in a little bit but
sven hansen again how will hamid karzai
go down in history what do you think
what's your take
i think he hasn't achieved that much but
on the other hand he has achieved
something which we first have to keep in
mind i mean he survived i think that's a
very big important thing
10 years 12 years ago nobody would have
believed in that that is one thing so
that is an achievement by itself and the
other achievement we will now see with
the elections
he allowed the first democratic
transition
hopefully peaceful transition to a newly
elected government that is also
something especially in that region
that's something so that might be his
biggest legacy
i think on other things
he has not achieved that much i mean you
mentioned already corruption and the
drugs and also peace development
i mean there are many many problems
nevertheless
he has somehow stabilized the whole on a
low level but as i said he survived and
now we can maybe move on so that's
something i would say and moving on is
certainly something that the country
needs desperately malaise doubt kunda
knob already pointed towards the fact
that hamid karzai was a u.s
candidate or rather the u.s pick you
shake your head already uh i'm sorry i'm
i'm bothered by stuff like this i would
be very honest and i would just put away
my
kind of analytical hat here look he
comes from a very prominent family in
the south his father was some 40-50
years ago the deputy speaker of the
parliament now tell me how he is a
puppet you know secondly he lived all
his life in the region either
afghanistan or pakistan thirdly in the
born conference all the major political
groups from the rome group to cyprus to
shower group to the former northern
alliance they're all present
his name was put forward and that name
was
that name gained the support of every
single political entity you cannot have
everyone around the table you have the
major forces if you look at all the
peace building and then the peace
projects what you have is you have the
main parties to the conflict of course
taliban were excluded only the top
leadership there are many taliban who
took part
in the the emergency lawyer who took
part in
in the constitutional laws again so this
guy has a history of politics in
afghanistan this is a misconception a
very common one among especially the
non-afghans in afghanistan we know who
he is who we know where he came from and
how he made it to this to the spot sorry
you said he lived all his life in the
region
but what about his years he spent in the
united states he didn't this is a
misconception it's his brothers who
lived in the us he was in pakistan and
afghanistan of course he traveled
broadly he was
you you have to look at some of the
pictures for example he was part of the
all negotiations between the wrong group
and the former northern alliance and he
was the most probably one of the very
few people from the rome group side who
was based in in pakistan afghanistan of
course his his father was killed in the
quite a city in pakistan what was he
doing there
and why was he killed by by the taliban
so my life's doubt clearly takes issue
with your assessment that he is a us
puppet yeah
um but he was he was he was he developed
i said he developed
yeah that was i think we can agree that
he and at least in the first years he
was very much depending on the support
by the us i mean he had no you know his
own armed groups he didn't have he has
no party so he has his tribe and of
course he had uh some backing and i mean
there was
who else you should have put hope on
in he was the only one so i mean the
the western countries put a lot of hope
in him and also of course the afghan i
mean it was a new start so he was the
one
to do it yeah but who wasn't dependent
on this support even today who isn't
dependent on the u.s support i was
listening to dr ashf
yesterday with the cnn and he said he
would
sign the bilateral security agreement
because that guarantees the survivor of
survival of our state still 12 years
down the line
everyone we were all dependent on this
support because we are facing this huge
threat from the other side which is the
terrorists supported by the pakistanis
and the arabs so we were all dependent
on it if you look at the
mohammed qazi is a political entity that
leads the group that lisa tribe he was
there he was doing it before the u.s
invasion and he will continue doing it
after the u.s troops leave or all the
troops well regardless of how you
perceive him or perceived him uh rather
in the beginning
one thing is for certain stan hunson has
already mentioned that he's the very
first afghan president to make way
for a peaceful or rather democratic
transition we will see how peaceful it
will actually be in
in the end and how democratic perhaps
but you give him credit for that you
give mohammed karzai credit for paving
the way
for
at least on paper a democratic
transition
yes to some extent yes
i would agree with you that he is a
very difficult seasoned african
politician and leader
by
let's say balancing the very different
tribes and forces
in afghanistan he was very cleverly
doing that and he did that more and more
proficiency professionally
this is what i credit to him no doubt
but then
without
the
let's say western support
no afghan could have done that and
achieved that yeah this is something you
know what is not characterized
let's say achievement it's simply the
western scheme and back to that
but what he did indeed was as i said
before
it's afghanistan was a war-torn
country
and it's now rather rather pacified
for the time being let's wait what
happened off what will happen after the
elections i'm very very about that too
but for the time being yes this was his
achievement in that sense i would
compare him to the former king of
afghanistan he was also not a politician
he didn't like that was not his uh role
model but to be king
uh he was somebody who was much more
interested in archaeology and all the
other beauties of on earth
but what he did and did the tv did not
very much but whenever the leftist or
left
meaning politicians or streamings in
afghanistan who came up too much
he calmed them down the rights came up
he gumped him down so he balanced the
former king like because i did it the
different
forces in afghanistan quite cleverly and
one major difference that karzai has
put in place way more democratic
practices
if he
could if he wanted he could reverse a
lot of those those
progresses that we've made but he hasn't
this is the choice he has made you know
i mean he's taken head on the u.s
especially after 2009 and he's extremely
powerful right now not only because of
the the disproportionately
central uh political system that we have
highly centralized political system but
also because of the the kind of support
he gets from the people the u.s itself
one of its institutions the asia
foundation foundation says that
85 percent of afghans support kaze still
12 years down the line i don't think any
head of state 12 years down the line
anywhere in the world will have that
record well despite the high approval
ratings that hamikar zai is enjoying
these days he will step down that's for
certain what is not for certain is who
will follow him many candidates have
lined up to succeed him but there are
three in particular who have the
greatest chances of taking over the
presidency let's have a look at these
candidates
the three presidential candidates with
the best chance of winning the election
are all established politicians abdullah
abdullah was foreign minister under
president karzai he did well against his
former boss in the 2009 presidential
election but dropped out of the runoff
vote citing election fraud if he wins
abdullah is promising to sign an
agreement with the united states that
would keep american troops in the
country beyond 2014.
is also backing the security deal which
president karzai has refused to endorse
ghani is a former finance minister who
has worked with the world bank and the
united nations but he has been
criticized for picking former warlord
abdul rashid dostoon as his running mate
zalmai rasool another former foreign
minister has been one of karzai's
closest confidants
his critics say that he's too close to
the corrupt administration that has run
afghanistan over recent years
well steven hansen we just saw the three
candidates one of them at least most
likely to become the next afghan
president now is this really a fresh
start we've seen and heard these
individuals have been in government
before they are highly established
political figures
in the country all faces really is the
old guard is is a fresh start possible
with these individuals
to a certain extent yes i mean they are
um
seized politicians but uh the the
difference
in regard to the last elections is we
have no clear favorite so we really have
a
more open debate and
a more
severe competition
um also the the whole system matured to
a certain extent so now you saw in the
picture we had tv debates
um the campaign rallies uh drawback
crowds and also the media asked more
critical questions so the people more
want to know what are you going to do if
you are elected i mean the answers you
can really debate on whether they are so
satisfactory but i think the the overall
level has has risen
and
also the
candidates matured in that sense that
they
tried to choose uh
their vice candidates from different
ethnic groups so they be to be try to be
more inclusive
so that i think is a progress so um and
i would say all three are uh
how to say our
potential presidents let's say the west
or or the international community can
work with so that i would agree and of
course malaysia
ethnic background matters in afghanistan
we know that ashraf ghani and zalmai
rasul are representing the pashtun
fraction whereas abdullah abdullah
is half-past and half-target but it's
more or less associated with the target
fraction do you think these factors will
uh be decisive in the outcome
um yes of course ethnicity is still
unfortunately a factor um however this
has been played down by some people but
some other people have tried to elevate
it to an extent to benefit from it um
well abdullah blah technically is also
pashtun because his father is pashtun
but because of his long association with
the
former northern alliance he's considered
more pro
pro
projects
the
ethnic
composition of the tickets itself was
not only because
these people belong to different
different ethnic groups but also because
of the kind of votes they were going to
bring to the tickets apart from the
ticket of the salma rasool if you look
at the shafgrani's ticket you've got
the former warlord dostum because
i mean
this guy will get like 90 percent of the
those back votes at least at least
and if you look at abdul abdullah's
ticket you've got muhammad khan who's a
pashtun i don't think they have any
major voter banks and then you have
and he's going to bring a lot of hazard
votes in the past he has proven that he
will get a lot of votes zalamed sue's
ticket is a very different ticket
because he's supported mainly by karzai
so he's just put people from other
ethnicities and this ticket but the
support will come from karzai's network
but he's the only one having a woman and
that is also something i mean that's a
kind of progress i would say
has just mentioned mohammed karzai has
thrown his backing behind rasul
many people even say this is his
backdoor really back through to
influencing things in afghanistan after
all hamid karzai is only 56 years old
relatively young for a former president
and he's decided he's made it clear he's
going to stay in the country he built a
villa in the palace he built a villa
relatively close so um do you also think
that theory is correct that once russell
becomes president really karzai is going
to stay on as a shadow president yes if
my doubts whether
these candidates i agree that their
seasoned politicians
will have
the power and the
proper maneuver to elope from the shadow
of karzai this is the other side of it
look here's the prevailing political
force and father of the nation something
like that put all the other things aside
so it will be difficult for them you
were asking is that a fresh start i have
my doubts it's not the real fresh start
it's simply at best it's a
continuation of a process what might be
good and this is particular
with regard to ash of ghani so it will
be difficult for them again to elope
from the shadow the overweight of kazai
and karzai does know that
and he's trying to save his
let's say
picture in history the future picture of
him
by installing or
proposing or supporting these candidates
whether it's him or him even abdul
abdullah if he would be elected
president he could not await that heavy
influence and
imagine a former president would stay on
the premises of the presidency
in germany than any other country so
this is a symbol a big big example it's
not the premises again another
misconception we had this tradition of
having different palaces it's one of
those palaces that is being renovated
for president karzai but he's staying
close he's staying with us it's not only
his decision it's the decision of all
the afghan elites you know
there were many consultations and people
knew that he deserved it anyhow secondly
no
not all the candidates are going to be
burdened by the influence of what
muhammad khazar did in his proximity to
the palace number one abdullah still has
a lot of resentment against karzai
especially because of the 2009 election
secondly
they say the ticket of abdullah very
close people to
abdullah and his
vice presidential candidates that kazakh
did everything to japanese their ticket
but he couldn't because all the other
tickets there are the architecture of
all other tickets was karzai this is
another fact
uh thirdly
sorry effect or saying that's successful
no it's a fact
it's a fact i've done my research i've
put it in my papers recently if you look
at it i've spoken to to the very closest
of all these people like those who went
to kazan and said what should i do you
know in the election he said go and
become the deputy of hashem
he came to him said okay i want to run
he said okay i'm here to support you so
run and then uh he asked his vice second
vice president to provide a second
deputy
to uh to ashavahani so they are all
puppets to uh except for definitely
because they knew that
they are not now they knew that without
his support they would not be able to
win so they all went to him and he told
almost everyone okay you're my candidate
you're my country apart from abdullah of
the law and you know what else he did
other people when they went to him and
said whom should we support he
distributed them very carefully you know
this former governor to this guy you go
to this guy you so that's what he's done
anyhow
ashfani initially thought he was the
favorite candidate of karzai but now
turns out it's zalmar rasool and
ashhafrani's campaign is resenting and
they are very very angry at what is
going on so if asha finally comes power
and because i vote very closely with
ashfani i think he will not be a happy
man with karzai and sven
the two brothers karzai's all the
brothers also
at some point threw their head in the
ring and took it out yeah and that's why
we all think that rasul is the canadian
of karzai because his brothers endorsed
rasool i mean officially kaza has not
endorsed anybody and i think that is
also smart not to do it and i think he
plays a kind of divide and rule tactics
but of course that gives his brothers
that gives a hind that probably karzai
is behind russell so in some shape or
form hamid karzai seems to
still uh will hold the grip perhaps on
afghan affairs yeah i mean his grip will
be the stronger the weaker the future
president will be i mean if he has if
there would be a president elected with
a very strong mandate very powerful
then that person can
be relatively free of the influence of
cornell but if it's a weak president
winning with
a small margin he might have to need he
might need the karzai's support to
to really make it and another another
challenge aside from who's going to win
is in 2009 we know that at least one
million votes were disqualified how
likely do you think election fraud is
going to be this time around
i think the
the chance is very high that there will
be election fraud uh what is still open
whether
in general the elections will be
regarded as credible i mean the the
technical challenge and the logistic
challenge the security challenge i mean
that's enormous so there will be
problems there will be fraud there will
be even between five and ten percent
of their polling stations not being able
to open that day because it's too
dangerous so you will find many many
uh reasons why you can always argue ah
this is not fair so the the it will be a
relative
relatively uh fair or not fair so that's
a big question
and
yeah i mean the there are changes or
let's say the situation is a bit
different than last time so like
now you have three candidates relatively
close together they have organized their
camp so they they watch each other quite
closely also the uh media are uh having
a closer look also their voters are
somehow more better educated or and so i
think
yeah the technology
now you have a barcode on and this
system um but on the other hand if if
you have more awareness people will also
see more uh rigging so that's the the
the the
contra productive effect that when
people are not caring that much they
won't see it now you will probably see
it everywhere so um yeah i think the big
that's a big question will these
elections be credible and i think the
credibility of the election is much more
important than who will finally win
and uh one thing we we know guntaq now
that we don't know if these elections
going to be free and fair the question
is how safe will they be because the
taliban has already vowed that they will
do everything within their power to
disrupt these elections they say anyone
who goes to the polls on saturday could
risk their life and already we've seen
unfortunately string of attacks which
have led to casualties um do you think
that will deter a great number of afghan
individuals to go and cause their vote
this is difficult to say that
of course the taliban are threatening
because they won't accept any kind of
election and nobody who is elected by
more or less democratic and free
elections so they tried their best to
disturb the
election process
but
to me it's surprising that they did not
more up to now to interfere
we have to wait to until election day
but i think the threat
which was spoken out and
proposed by the taliban is not that big
up to now as one had to expect
this is amazing to me or surprising or
it's a good sign why do you think that
is because they're not as strong anymore
or because they're restraining
themselves
difficult to say um maybe they're not
strong and
that the afghan security forces are much
stronger now
the taliban are losing finances the
saudi
sheikhs are now diverting their
resources to the syrian conflict uh the
afghan businessmen who are based in
pakistan
simulators of pakistani season
journalists has done a brilliant piece
on this they because of the taliban with
brutality their sheer
criminality they are now not not willing
to pay for taliban anymore pakistan is
at its
feet because economically pakistan is
not a viable state anymore just recently
saudi arabia gave it 1.5 billion dollars
so taliban simply don't have the
resources second thing is the afghan
security forces are much stronger now
i see a different aspect of it
the taliban are still i think
preparing for the time after the
election
and
any
maneuver or any killing of afghan people
during this election process would black
blacken their face much more than before
so they might also think we avoid to do
that
so that after the election we are still
accepted by afghan people when we start
some kind of talks political talks with
the then president and government about
any kind of participating in the
government coalition or whatever so that
might be also a very clever political
movement by the taliban
how strong are the taliban do you think
they will
regain the same stature
that they had prior to the u.s invasion
in 2001
i mean that's depending on on a lot of
different factors and i
think one factor will be how credible
will the elections be how
legitimate will be seen the the new
president
but i also would argue that the
television they have an image problem or
they have to care about their image they
recently when they attacked the serena
hotel they at point black
shot two small kids i mean
that's
very bad for their image i would say i
mean that was not people killed in
crossfire but it was
cold blooded murder of children i mean
it's really crazy so and that i mean i
think if the it's not a question of
resources or financial resources whether
you are able to to blow up a campaign
meeting of 10 000 people i think they
would have the capabilities to do it but
it would uh
it
it yeah but i mean they they influence
they have suicide
bombers uh i think that they don't have
a lack of that so but
the question is would it be a smart move
from from the side and i said i would
say it's not smart
therefore probably they have not done it
but
they would have to have the capabilities
yeah i don't know what source your
argument is based on
there's a recent paper
by the afghan analyst network in which
the author says that from the seven
districts of ghazni where taliban had
most of its foot soldiers in in this
province and surrounding provinces in
the past one year they got only three
people now five willing to fight for
them so that's also winning it's also
human resources financial resources
weapons and everything else
of course the shared brutality also
plays a big role and the serena attack
was not the first one for the past five
years they can become more brutal uh
against civilians because simply they
cannot target the targets they want to
target there are videos of taliban
playing football with the heads of of uh
people they've killed and that takes a
toll the afghan people now overwing
willingly reject their way of governance
and to the question of whether taliban
are
playing awaiting they're not they know
that the best bet for them is karzai
because he is considering so much to
them after kazai it's an unknown
territory
they're not like to to tread when it
comes to the fraudulent elections
look the problem again is not 2009. the
problem started in 2004 with the first
presidential election the fraud was done
especially by the international
community the us
knowingly
did a lot of trouble to make sure that
karzai is elected you know so it started
that
moving out to 2005 there were more fraud
and then 2009 it came to blows because
president kaze simply wouldn't accept
that what robert gates puts as a failed
push of the international community
against them that's why it came to the
to the four even the media the western
media turned a blind eye to the share
corruption that was done in 2004 and
2005. because
these elections the former elections and
this these elections
will be presented to the west as look we
went to afghanistan
to
export or missionary
i call it the democracy missionary
election so they want to prove look
there was democracy brought by us
to afghanistan and the election should
be approved to the public in our
countries these elections are important
because these are organized
now these elections are important
because they are face saving measure for
the west to leave the country so the
west needs these elections whether there
is a fraud or not the west is not
inclined to to criticize the fraud i
mean the the motivation of the west is
we want to live and therefore we want to
show that it's not that bad what we have
done there so therefore we need
elections who somehow more or less
worked
so even if there is uh the same level of
fraud the criticism would be less
because we want to leave we that's
that's over yes
because you know only one candidate
is deploying 30 000 observers uh the
free and fair election uh
foundation of afghanistan is deploying
10 000 uh observers and as i said
technology there are people 18 million
people with mobile phones so even if the
us doesn't want it our media is
proactive and you are going to see
everything that is going to happen but
of course van hansen you are right
because 2014 is a very decisive year for
afghanistan not because of the elections
but also as you've alluded to the isif
troops are leaving the isif mission is
coming to an end at the end of the year
uh if if you think about how it all
started with more than 40 nations and
140 000 troops uh big mission back post
started very small uh
it started small
6 000 and even
like uh mr vandrel the former
uin
how to say the the special environment
and then later the deputy special
android he said six thousand not enough
we need at least thirty thousand and and
those days everybody said nobody would
give you thirty thousand soldiers so uh
but in the end in the beginning it only
started six thousand in in kabul andreas
said now we need some for herod for maja
for canada so for the big cities we need
thirty thousand and then it uh it took
years until it was uh soldiers are
always asking for more soldiers if they
don't visit yeah but he wasn't
this was fighting against the terrorism
of al qaeda but that then developed into
a war in afghanistan and partly against
afghanistan well
it started small but it certainly
blossomed into one of the bigger
international operations in recent years
and and the question that i would have
now that supposedly the troops are are
leaving afghanistan
how do the average afghans
perceive this uh coming withdrawal is it
is it a joy is it the fact that finally
we get to take matters into our own
hands or is is perhaps fear also a
factor here
yeah fear is a factor on the other hand
i mean the when the troops came they
were relatively welcomed warmly welcomed
most of them and they are not that
warmly received anymore because they
they made a lot of mistakes and
yeah but there's now a lot of
uncertainty and um
i mean the the afghan troops have
learned a lot but still there's a
question whether they could do it alone
so the the kind of compromise is now
they need more training and what i see
the biggest problem is they not only
need training but they need money i mean
their salary has to be paid and that's a
big risk and also maybe the big mistake
in the end arrested you you created a
huge
armed forces
and if they run out of control you
create the next civil war or the next
big problem so you have to pay them
but even if you pay them you're not
cannot be sure about their loyalty
and if you're not paying them
that's creating trouble so
yeah i think that's a big risk and
that's also where the afghans are maybe
at the moment they see okay our forces
are better maybe then or more
um
more sensible to our
our sentiments than than american forces
or german forces
but
we don't know when they are not being
paid they they become
criminals armed criminals
so mixed emotions then
about the withdrawal
of isaf troops my lies doubt still the
the question is has security and life of
for the average afghan really improved
uh during these uh past decade really of
of uh foreign troops presence it's
really difficult to say to be honest
it's a huge country every area has
different dynamics so you have to look
at the country and analyze every part of
the country a different way
here's the thing you know
we the the urban
areas have improved drastically you know
again for example in my province of
practica we didn't have a single meter
of paved road you know and now we have
paved those roads all over you know
schools are open clinics are open
and of course people have the
opportunity to participate in the in the
decision-making process of the country
though it's still in a very elitist
country in a sense because elites have
everything and the common people suffer
but but
seeing how the lives are affected that's
why some of the studies are informed by
by the
by
by the uh impact that this intervention
has left seventy plus people percent
people of afghanistan
still approve of the intervention even
the presence of the american troops
whereas in pakistan ninety percent
people think this is the biggest enemy
in egypt ninety percent
people think
u.s is the biggest enemy so you had a
military presence still more than 70
people that's not only because of the
kind of of
of what what the international forces
did but also because we have so many
other political
forces in the region that we prefer the
western international forces rather than
the
the region so
i would say
it's been positive generally speaking of
course there have been lots of problems
too
and guitar kinaba since malaysia
mentioned pakistan it's an important
factor it has been an important factor
in afghanistan but so have been iran uh
uh and even india to a certain degree
how do you think these these nations
surrounding and neighboring nations will
position themselves after the election
they are all
observing afghanistan since years very
kingly
and first starting with pakistan
pakistan and afghanistan i consider it
as being xiaomi's
twins you can't
divide them without bloodshed
the the borderline is not a border it's
simply passionate area settlements
and the enmity between the afghans and
the pakistani in general
is deeply since historical for
historical reasons afghans still don't
accept or recognize the durian blind
which was drawn as a friendship between
afghanistan and pakistan this is deep in
the minds of the afghans and on the
other hand pakistan still considers at
least parts of pakistan consider
afghanistan as something like it should
be a protectorate of pakistan sorry of
pakistan yes right so
this is a deep ingrained enmity
and on the other hand pakistan still is
trying to have more influence upon
afghanistan which is a problem for the
americans too on the other hand
it's still the region of retreat for the
terrorists and
islamistic
terrorists
then
the enemy of pakistan is india and the
enemy of my enemy is my friend therefore
afghans like for one reason
like india quite much it's the most
popular country according to paul's
recent polls in afghanistan
of course india also wants to
counterbalance pakistan with influence
in afghanistan iran has got a vested
interest in afghanistan due to the shia
groups in afghanistan mainly the hazara
minority and to the north
they are very much afraid tajikistan
uzbekistan of developments in
afghanistan there is comes in one thing
we didn't mention yet the drug
production and export of drugs towards
the north the west the west the east
this is something which they are very
much concerned about
terrorists from afghanistan may be again
and mainly drugs
and since we're running out of time
slowly let me get your quick assessments
fran hansen what do you think will
happen what's the most likely outcome of
the presidential election then we will
have a second round
and that
probably the the loser i mean the third
guy
he will cry forward
and then the question is how credible
can he cry forward
malaysia two scenarios will either have
one of the three major candidates
elected in the second round
and the second scenario is there could
be a lot of fraud there would be far of
course and then uh there would be all
the the cries and the crisis and this
will actually benefit president karzai
to stay on for another year because it
will go on for such a very long time
good day
well and whoever will lose the elections
he will claim for the reasons when
hanson mentioned there was fraud and
there were no elections at all in many
provinces and districts so
they will claim or the loser will claim
losers will claim
these elections are not valid
while valid or not we will have an
election coming up a very decisive
election for the future afghanistan and
of course we will continue to follow
this story very closely along with my
experts whom i want to thank for a very
lively and engaging discussion
thank you out there of course for tuning
in
and looking forward to seeing you again
next week for a new edition of quadriga
you